[Music]
in anti VidCon news that's a bit comes
from VidCon VidCon is great white
submitted by faithful jamali and
citizens thank you what a good boy or
girl that's that's for the middle or
multi by there's a lot of females that
are trying to live people that don't
identify as either all right that's the
modern one let's just not make it
complicated all right you this is Joe
Mallya author youtuber Tana mojo through
her own creator convention during VidCon
but it got cancelled for being a chaotic
mess I had tickets to tannic on yeah I
didn't want it all right we were
supposed to go with like for a video for
our company so they we bought tickets I
did not get in what did they do tannic
on it was right next to VidCon it was at
the Marriott next to VidCon home it was
supposed to be like so you could walk
there like it's Batman hey I'm gonna try
to like do this as unbiased as possible
Tana mojo didn't get a featured creator
badge for two years and she was pissed
she has millions of subscribers yeah
yeah she's got more than one because
she's kind of a little controversial
sometimes you know like it's yes but at
the Creator badge they give us that [ __ ]
Tana and she it was it was definitely
like a [ __ ] you to VidCon I'm gonna hold
my own convention next door to VidCon
and I can do just as well so she had a
lot of big like should a lot of big
people there she had Shane Dawson I know
Miranda sings was there going uh yeah
Bella Thorne was there like she has some
pretty big names but she kept tweeting
the tickets are free just come through
like if you're at VidCon so it was
definitely like I try to say like screw
you VidCon I'm gonna take your people
and she didn't she just didn't plan it
correctly and like over 5,000 people
showed up and they did not have
accommodations for it they sold tickets
and you arranged me that like people
showed up oh yeah but the police and
everything said no it was 5,000 I'm
trying to be unbiased here but yet like
she the biggest issue with it was that
they sold tickets ranging from $65 to
over $200 VIP but they had there was one
line and it was free tickets no tickets
and VIP so some people that pay it on
the rise we're in the back of the line
we had $65 tickets but we didn't go
because we heard that it was a mess but
I got my Tanic on sticker yeah I thought
that's the best the team you know why
does she want what's oh I don't
understand like why is she so offended
oh okay okay that makes sense because
like I like that completely makes sense
like you know being included and being
excluded from something that you feel
like you deserve at that age it's a big
deal yeah so she felt like a 1 hour and
something when it's rants about her
experience with VidCon for the past two
years and so for the first year she they
didn't give a creator path even though
she had a ton of followers so every time
she went anywhere she said that she
would cause a commotion become people
got very upset with her and to the point
where they kicked her out and then they
were like you know what I just don't say
anything like be good about this and
then you'll get one next year oh the
other reason what she's really pretty
but they kept promising her as she would
get a future creator so she would
promote it she would promote it like
crazy and there were people future
create mass that's different from a
creator past yeah yeah so she did she
didn't even give her a clear path or she
wanted specifically a featured creator I
mean I don't know she was saying that
she finessed her way in so I don't think
she had a pass at all I don't really
know the point is she the second year at
some point the next year she had her
face plastered all over VidCon cause she
was part of this show yeah she was part
of escape and I gave them
so like people were wearing masters over
fate like literally her face was
plastered everywhere in the wall they
still didn't give her a pass faces all
the [ __ ] on the building that's like
UFC it's like caught McGregor in the
bait where they're gonna fight and then
Mayweather I mean can't come in I can
see from vidcon standpoint because I
don't remember the whole idubbbz
constant cop thing that came out with
her no that was pretty bad I had over 20
million
I know nothing about you - yeah she will
just a video came out of her like saying
the n-word like just cavalierly like
casually and I'd have made a whole video
on it know what's like what's the class
she's repeating what she in a video you
know you're a stupid n-word right oh she
was like way younger so and then there
was a couple there was like another
video where she said it too so and but
to be fair she said that when she was
way younger she was like 15 or 16 and
like people change whatever yada yada
yada
i I firmly believe that I was actually a
TANF and I have some pictures on my
Instagram with Tana and I look like a
fangirl I'm like this but I can
understand why VidCon would be afraid to
have this controversial person as a
featured creator I get that but also I
don't think any it was like two years
ago I don't think anyone would care like
she's so big everyone would understand
like she should be the first especially
if she's playing there her face is on
there yeah you're gonna play her on the
building give her a bad make she was on
panels like they had her do like I skip
the room thing with fans too and they
still wouldn't give her the badge think
it's kind of weird
yeah so like the little reason why she
wanted the badges because the security
kept getting mad at her and the event
people keep getting mad at her for
causing a crazy emotion but she can't go
anywhere behind the scenes because she
never had she she couldn't go backstage
because she didn't she pissed somebody
off
yeah and they were doing that to get
back at her yup so who did she piss well
I invited her back in the night because
that's the part to piss her off
that's the best appoint they're pissing
her off on purposes so she definitely
has a bad relationship with somebody in
there that refuses to give her the -
just to think of [ __ ] with well good for
her because a lot of people talk but not
a lot of people walk and she [ __ ]
shot Mary and she did her own [ __ ] you
know that's very poor planning obviously
it wasn't gonna come out you know what's
so wild I could say the same thing and
I'll pull a David Kahn and 12 people
will show up and they would just make
fun of me could it be so sad I know what
half of those were I know just you guys
there I'm thank you and she rallied up
other like notable youtubers time cuz
other youtubers were like well [ __ ]
we got [ __ ] over - and then they went
over to that you know they went to both
oh I just don't think there were people
saying that a lot of these creators that
went to her convention they had like
their badge to go to hers if they had a
VidCon badge and VidCon said well if you
have her it hurt my badge frickin
wristband thank you you can't come in
through space like they were like I mean
that's what she was saying yeah that's
what she said alive and then somebody
has a video where they pulled up to
VidCon and they said things like being
snarky they were like hey where's Tanic
on and then the parking attendant was
like oh it's not the Marriott why would
the staff get off they tweeted out hey
if you're going to VidCon or tan economy
show you have a great night
be safe yeah yeah they're also also let
me show you guys a clip of the crowd
panic on oh that's definitely not 20,000
people though here yeah it's like 5,000
amount of people oh wow oh [ __ ]
I still a lot of people that's only
5,000 people that is a lot okay don't
forget that one spot that looks good
barbeque
oh she married my whole satanic auger
for VidCon so what is she do very funny
man this world is crazy dude I'm so
disconnected I mean YouTube's got
[ __ ] bigger they sold 5,000 tickets
and the mass capacity of the biggest
room was 400 so like they would get
roughly and then between the hallway
that room and something else they'd get
700 people in and then they'd say okay
we have to kick everyone else out to get
the next 700 people and they're like if
you want to come back in you got to get
back at the end of the line and so
people were like what
so people were tweeting like parents
were like I took off work Friday like we
came from Calgary kit like Calgary
whatever like we came from Maine we
drove down here are you gonna reimburse
us for driving like yadda yadda yadda so
it was bad dude I really need to be
reconnected with this world not because
I want to be a part of it but I think I
should know this stuff like I'm so like
also it's a lot of T David damned I
don't know who the [ __ ] this person is I
don't know these kids like why they
would go like I feel but also there's
just so much now there's just a lot of
content it's really different from when
we were making out you like videos of
kangaroo punching people in the face of
[ __ ] dude you should go to kanga Khan
yeah dude literally my whole feed is
watching Muay Thai people chop the [ __ ]
out of somebody's [ __ ] torso yeah I
think that's like all my feed and then I
watched somebody doing muy Thai in the
screens oh wow yeah it was like you know
people just don't know who the [ __ ] they
are
I need a reset my feet cuz that's a dope
feet do it that's all I watched and then
watch kangaroos punching other people
then I see a puppy trying to climb
stairs and [ __ ] do puppy kangaroo calm
how cute that's what I need to do oh
yeah they were saying that people were
waiting out and you know the first clip
where everyone was waiting outside that
they were waiting for like five hours
and there's nothing they were just
burning and burning I haven't done
VidCon in the past two years but I did
go to the studio 71 party at the House
of Blues how come you talk Julia but not
me because it was brief we were looking
for somebody went to the bathroom and
they she was there in fact she was by
herself I would say they left you here
no she can't freakin straggling out like
I don't know what the [ __ ] was going on
we're like Julia catch up what the [ __ ]
Julia who she was playing Pokemon go and
she was finding the interesting Pokemon
she kept [ __ ] going off on her all
well I joined a stick with a Julia stick
with her can't do it without a mutant
hey Julia well okay I was on a plane
leader texting me ya know but it was
really dope though it wasn't invited cuz
you know most of the parties and all
that stuff it's for the creators so like
you know like you you you were there but
it was like one after the other
there's just people that you know so it
feels like a good reunion hmm versus
like big cons like heck hmm
yeah it's Raza Unida great [ __ ] what I
saw a meet-and-greet
looks hectic yeah our playlists meet
agree it was [ __ ] off the chain yeah
nobody three people showed up over you
look over no cuz they wanted to have a
like [ __ ] out like 11:00 a.m. and like
none of our fans go to playlist yeah
yeah we are like three people we know
I went to a convention and I don't
remember where I think it was Oh Pat it
was one of the packs conventions I had
more people recognize me from JK than
from Smosh but like all the JK people
were real show they're like hey you know
JK what kind of convention it was it was
at a gaming convention at PAX you guys
[ __ ] up dude if we were at boba con
we'd be [ __ ] done BZ everybody want a
piece of this [ __ ] dude oh you know what
me anime convention and we had a [ __ ]
bigger line than the people that were
paid to be at the event okay you see me
at the k-town night market I'm swimming
and [ __ ] dicks and [ __ ] all day I
don't know I feel like I become I I say
something slightly gangster I have to do
the the West Side it's black yeah yeah
dinosaur hands cuz it's not even
properly done like with confidence so
it's like oh yeah I do morning dear
[Music]